the goal of this line is to invoke the
car function such that its parameter
this is bound to the van instance and to
do that we are also going to have to use
the keyword this inside the van function
since it's bound to the right object in
there at the heart of this confusion is
the fact that there are two different
parameters in two different scopes both
of which are given the name this but we
must keep in mind that the parameter
this behaves just like other positional
parameters two functions for example
it's probably not confusing that the
local from inside van is being passed
along as the first argument to car where
it's coincidentally given the same name
even though the two variables share the
same name we think of them as different
because they're in different scopes the
shared name is incidental and this line
merely passes along the binding from one
function to another the same is true of
the parameter this it's just being
passed in a bit different way to
underscore this point let's consider a
snippet from a totally separate math
library the double function calls the
product function passing along its X
variable to the product function where
and it's going to be given the name a
that example was uncontroversial but
what if we were to use the same argument
name in both functions how would you
expect that to affect how our code runs
in fact there's no change to how these
two functions would behave the new
example would seem almost as
uncontroversial as the previous one even
though both functions have an input
named num it's clear that those names
are coincidental the code behaves the
same as if they were actually named
differently since the two variables are
in different scopes interestingly the
situation is almost exactly the same
when we pass along the value 3 to be
bound to the parameter this if we use
the same binding to the parameter this
in our above function call we have
ourselves the same situation where two
different parameters in two different
scopes happen to share a name and again
we are just invoking the function a
little differently so that we are
allowed to bind the value to the
parameter this